[Music]
the big bang theory is huge
it informs the origins of the entire
universe
however there's a lot more to this
theory than just a colossal explosion it
also explains how the universe continues
to expand and it sheds light on the
birth of new stars
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream
in this episode of perspectives five
experts discuss the development of the
big bang theory and its many lasting
effects
we begin now with an overview of the
theory itself and some insights into why
it was initially panned by the
scientific community
enjoy
[Music]
the current theory of the history of the
universe is called the standard
cosmological model
based on evidence from a wide variety of
telescopes and from theoretical models
astronomers have deduced that the
universe began about 13.7
billion years ago in an event called the
big bang
the big bang wasn't really an explosion
as much as the sudden appearance of
space-time with an equivalent
temperature of about a trillion degrees
in a billionth of a billionth of a
billionth of a second space expanded by
a billion billion billion times an
expansion that continues to this day
although at a much slower rate
scientists hated this idea
first of all we don't see this sort of
event regularly and have never seen
versions of it under laboratory
conditions
why should we think such a thing
happened
unique events seem utterly unscientific
to claim that we can rewind the film to
a point where all mass and energy is
concentrated at a single point only to
explode into a universe like ours is
tantamount to theology
it's positing a creation event that
grossly outruns what we can infer from
the fact that the galaxies are moving
away from each other if you want to say
there was a big bang that brought our
universe into its current state at some
point in the past
well what caused it and what happened
before that
these are questions for which there
could not even possibly be empirical
answers they aren't scientific questions
the big bang theory itself does seem
like fantasy
not real scientific work
there were scientific advantages for a
big bang theory if it were true then it
would offer a solution to a problem
called ober's paradox named after the
german astronomer heinrich wilhelm
olbers
problem simple
proposition 1 space is big
really big
proposition two there are lots of stars
out there lots and lots of stars so
putting one and two together if you
point to any spot in the sky and travel
in that direction far enough you'll
eventually hit a star
proposition three
stars shine
that is they emit light right that's
what we see up in the sky now putting
one two and three together if every
point in the sky leads to a star and the
light of that star is visible in the
night sky then the entire night sky
ought to be glowing
it should be as bright in the night as
it is in the day
so why is night dark
big bang theory gives us a nice easy
answer
the universe is of a finite age it might
be true that there's a star along any
line you point out but it takes an
amount of time for the light to get to
earth and if the star is far enough away
the light hasn't had time to get here
the idea behind the big bang basically
goes like this
as the universe expands and space gets
bigger the matter in it gets diluted
this means that in the future the
density of the universe will be lower
than it is today
and that in the past it was higher than
it is now
this also means that the universe was
hotter in the past
if we go back far enough in time
we would eventually find a period in
which the entire universe was filled
with an ultra hot soup of matter and
radiation
all at temperatures of thousands of
degrees or higher
so hot that even atoms themselves
couldn't stay intact
these are the kinds of conditions that
today you would find inside of a star
this hot era in our universe's early
history is what cosmologists now call
the big bang
this big bang theory makes many testable
predictions including that of a
background of microwave radiation that
should have been generated as universe
expanded and cooled and today this
background fills all of space
this cosmic microwave background was
first detected in 1964
and has been measured a greater and
greater precision ever since
as this and other evidence accumulated
in support of the big bang more and more
scientists became convinced of the
validity of this theory today there's
essentially universal agreement among
scientists at our universe evolved from
a hot state
over a period of about 13.8 billion
years
the idea of a cosmic microwave
background can be traced back to ralph
alpher and robert herman
two american cosmologists who first
proposed the idea in 1948
working forward from the big bang and
using edwin hubble's famous equation and
constant for describing the expansion of
the universe
they estimated a black body temperature
of 5 kelvin for the background radiation
of the modern universe
it would be over a decade before several
scientists either rediscovered their
work or made their own predictions on
how this background radiation could be
observed with estimates moving ever
closer to the radiation's true
temperature of 2.7 kelvin
one of these scientists was a physicist
named robert dickey who had studied the
question of the temperature of space for
years and invented the most widely used
microwave detector design while working
at mit
by 1964 he was at princeton and hard at
work on a painstaking scientific mission
to search for and hopefully detect the
cosmic microwave background and with it
the first robust observational proof of
the big bang
several colleagues at princeton had
joined him in the search
jim peebles had recently written about
how to detect and identify this
radiation and was preparing to publish
his results
while david todd wilkinson and peter
roll began building a top-notch
microwave detector following dickey's
design
this was after all the best design for
microwave antennae in the world a design
shared by the bell labs antenna just up
the road
arno penzias was born in munich germany
in 1933 and his life may well have been
saved by a radio signal
at age six he and his brother were among
the 10 000 jewish children evacuated to
the united kingdom a rescue operation
known as kindertransport
after a broadcast was sent out via bbc
radio asking for foster homes for
children fleeing nazi-occupied parts of
europe just before the start of world
war ii
his family was eventually reunited in
new york city
where he earned an undergraduate degree
in physics from the city college of new
york and a doctorate from columbia
university
robert wilson a few years younger than
penzias was born and raised in houston
texas
spending time in the oil fields where
his father worked as a chemical engineer
he described himself as a middling
student in high school but following his
father's footsteps to rice university he
earned a degree in physics before moving
to caltech for his phd
wilson joined penzias at bell labs and
the two began working with the holmdel
horn antenna a 20-foot radio detector
built atop crawford hill in new jersey
it had originally been used to capture
radio signals from an early nasa
communications satellite
when that communication project ended
penzias and wilson took over use of the
antenna
they hoped to repurpose it for radio
astronomy and study how radio signals
interacted with earth's atmosphere
however when penzias and wilson first
started pointing the new jersey antenna
at empty patches of sky
a standard step to calibrate the
detector
they kept picking up the same background
noise a kind of microwave static
what's more unlike carl jansky's
detection of radio waves from the center
of our galaxy
this static kiss seemed to be coming
from everywhere popping up in their data
no matter where they pointed the
telescope
penzias and wilson soon realized that
what they had found at bell labs could
potentially be this theorized cosmic
microwave background and placed a call
to dickie at princeton to learn more
about the phenomenon and share what
they'd found it just so happened that
dickie was in a meeting with his
colleagues when the call came through
after hearing what penzias and wilson
had found he hung up
turned to his fellow physicists and said
well boys we've been scooped
when the big bang spread matter across
the universe it did so ever so slightly
unevenly so the force due to gravity was
ever so slightly uneven
and matter started to attract other
matter well unevenly
eventually a big collection of hydrogen
and helium collected into a large cloud
contracting further and further under
the influence of gravity as the cloud of
gases contracted
two properties increased pressure of the
cloud and the temperature of the cloud
at some point thanks to gravity the
temperature and the pressure of the
cloud got so large atoms got pressed
together
that the electrons and the atoms were so
ignored and the atomic nuclei began to
come together under the influence of the
strong nuclear force what i'm describing
is nuclear fusion and a star is born
now nuclear fusion gives off a lot of
energy and the pressure generate
generated by this energy halts the
collapse of the cloud further for
millions billions of years
but let's focus on what happens in
nuclear fusion
atoms literally combine their nuclei to
make larger nuclei larger atoms
and the conditions aren't like right
after the big bang when fundamental
particles are trying to come together in
the vast expanse of space
well they can't the space is too vast
in a star however the atoms are crowded
together brought together by the
inexorable force of gravity
to give you an idea of the conditions
scientists estimate that the inside of a
star has a temperature of several
million degrees and a pressure of over a
hundred billion times the normal
atmospheric pressure on earth
after the big bang all of the matter of
the visible universe was all tightly
clustered with tons of gravity
however as the universe expanded matter
was farther apart which means that the
gravitational force drops over time
much like it does as a ball thrown
upward at great velocities
this has consequences on the prediction
of how the universe will expand after
the big bang
if the mass of the universe is too small
the universe will expand forever always
slowing but never stopping
if the mass of the universe is too large
it will expand for a long time but
eventually the gravitational force will
overcome the expansion of the big bang
and it will stop and then crash in on
itself this is called the big crunch
and if the mass of the universe is
exactly perfectly right the universe
will expand forever always slowing and
eventually stop the expansion at time
equals infinity
those are the options big crunch expand
and stop or expand and never stop one
two or three
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
on one dream and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel for
new episodes of perspectives and you can
watch previous ones here
[Music]